Arielle is on the line Ariel's in
Georgia hi Ariel welcome to Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thank you so much for
taking my call
hey how are you I'm good thank you
hey so I've been struggling with doing
my meds right for my bipolar two
disorder for about a year now I'm
working with a psychiatrist I have the
distancing he Barry's been one of those
that I can't seem to quite curb is my
spending
I'm not putting up into more debt but
I'm definitely not helping us when
babies but number two we're currently
hoarding money during a coronavirus
shuttle we're trying to save as much as
we can but my question is how long or
how do I help curb that need to spend so
I'm not hindering us from getting out of
debt as fast as we possibly can
so what is that what is this compulsion
feel like what does it look like for you
um I get real anxious I feel like I need
to buy something to fill a void okay so
so what I would bipolar obviously has
got a lot of history to it it's it's
probably one of the most diagnosed
mental health issues in the country and
it's probably one the most over
diagnosed mental health issues - and
bipolar - is notoriously challenging to
to regulate and to diagnose how long
have you been working with a
psychiatrist
around a year now okay so what I would
do out short of saying something that I
would tell you that you may feel is
unhelpful which would be just stop I
would put some prohibitory behaviors in
your world right I would put some blocks
that are gonna make it challenging for
you and that may mean having some rules
about not get on the computer not
purchasing things giving over your debit
card to your husband putting people in
your life they're gonna prohibit you
from that behavior and more importantly
finding some alternative behaviors that
are gonna fill that anxiety gap for you
I love that you've already framed it
that way that you feel it rise up and
you as this compulsion that you have to
go do a thing that means that you can
come up with other behaviors that are
more positive for you and it may be like
taking a walk and maybe going to
exercise it may be doing something nice
for somebody but it's
finding a behavior that's and gonna give
you that same dopamine hit the buying
something is but isn't gonna hurt your
family in this time of trying to save
your money right yeah Ariel we've worked
I don't know anything a near as much
about this as John does but I've ended
up as you might guess over the thirty
years of doing the financial crisis I've
ended up working with a bunch of bipolar
folks over the years and the good news
that I've seen is is the ones and I can
hear the way you're framing your
sentences and the way your thought
patterns are about this that you're
really making dramatic progress mm-hmm
and you know you you're getting you know
you're happening to this situation more
than it's happening to you now and
that's the beginning of healing so
congratulations that's a hard fight
you're in and the way I would treat it
if I were in your shoes or your
husband's shoes is just say you know
this person you when you're in that
manic state or whatever state it is
that's causing you to spin you like John
said you've got to have some things
around you any money it's okay it's not
saying that you you are permanently
disabled or something like that it's
okay to turn all the money over to him
for a little while until you get the
other side of this
I'll take give you another example I've
worked with couples where one of them is
addicted to cocaine and there's 100% of
cocaine addicts eventually or bankrupt
unless they get healed of the cocaine
right and so I just take the money away
from that person while they're healing
and any controls and treat them and
don't take this wrong but I to protect
you from you
and and your family for a short period
of time I just treat them like they're
four year old and I just say I'm gonna
take care of you and you're at your
husband is going to do that and you're
gonna turn the stuff over to him you're
doing that right now while you're
rational and then and then progressively
and incrementally as you get control
over these things that I think you're
close to that just listening to you I'm
not a dock that's not worth anything
when I said
but but incrementally as you sense
healing and since control over these
behaviors then you return he starts
returning elements a debit card
discussion about the budget something
that doesn't bring anxiety to you and
you participate gradually and
incrementally more and more as you heal
and get your may and you may be some
pharmacology that you get under control
and get balanced it takes a little while
to do that and but but you know in other
words it's not forever
it's until it's like you've been in a
car wreck and until you heal you can't
do this mmm that kind of a thing is
that's the way I look at it from a
practical standpoint I don't know how
that frames up with doc stuff though
what do you think John I think the fact
that you're asking this question tells
me yeah I think Dave you're right you're
down the road do you take your meds when
you're up in down or do you have seasons
where oh good for you I'm high-fiving
you from your we're in Georgia high-five
to you here from from Nashville that's
usually one of the bigger challenges
folks quit taking their medication so
one thing that's gonna be a gift to you
is what I'll call a series of little
wins and so writing a letter to your
husband or having a small note that says
I'm turning this over for this season is
gonna that you not something he's taken
from you but something that you are
giving to him yeah is gonna be a moment
where you're gonna have a little win
here that you're taking control of this
and then the next thing is gonna be an
in place of this behavior I'm gonna do
the following I'm gonna do some time to
go for a walk when I feel that that that
anxiety Mike I know that feeling you're
talking about me and it just started
wadding up and you're in your chest
there yeah good where you are real proud
of you you're doing good stuff and all
that's I predict a year from now you've
got a completely different life I think
you're on that track I really do and so
anything we're doing is just you know
again it's like somebody's been in a car
wreck we give them time to heal in a
year from now you know I got a friend of
mine that was in a horrible car wreck
and she's at Christmas and she's just
now mmm you know down here close to May
it is able to move and is ambulatory and
all it takes a while to heal from from
an injury and mental health is no
different than physical health in that
regard right and I would even say you
don't have to have bipolar or about car
wreck to say in this season I need to
turn my computer off right because I get
extra stress
and so then I watched too much Netflix
and then I stay up too late and then I
don't sleep well and then I start
looping right so I think all of us
whether you have a bipolar diagnosis or
a car wreck or just a regular person
walking down the street all of us need
to know I need to get out of this
behavior right now I need to have an
accountability partner I need to turn
this particular I need to have someone
ask me do you really want that other
bowl ice cream right and you have that
those those checks and balances 'm for
you Ariel that's very good you know and
it just just I mean I looked up and you
know and I'm working mmm I'm gonna work
every day and I still looked up and I've
gained five pounds oh man
and I already was overweight it's just
not cool Dave and I tell Sharon and of
course my wife's a health nut and so
she's got like zero body fat which is
simultaneously wonderful since she's my
wife but also shaming right sure and so
so you know about a week and a half ago
at then two miles every morning I just
had to go do something good for you you
know it's well just waddle my little fat
butt down the street but yeah but I but
I'm doing it you know and so was walking
up the stairs yesterday in my house I
went downstairs did all my morning
routine hug the kids hug my wife and I
was walking up the stairs mindlessly
this is like 8:30 in the morning with a
bag of chips and some Easter candy and I
I do this for a living
peeps are the are CBS's cocaine man yes
but I thought what are you doing and so
yeah I asked my wife I need you to step
in and help me in this while I
transition Sharon didn't hesitate to
help in that regard but uh because she
just loves health food anyway but oh my
gosh so yeah I mean but you know what's
it where it is instantly within two days
of starting to do a two-mile walk every
morning mmm feel better feel better your
brain clears up and you're not this
screen because there's nothing on this
screen that helping me nope
it's little winds all the way to about
200 emails they're helping probably
think you know running the business here
but but looking at this jeesus world on
the screen all day long
it just don't walk right go for a while
beautiful birds are out